is a kiosk going to stop a criminal well
the latest liberal solution to combat
skyrocketing retail theft has some
scratching their heads New York city
mayor Eric Adams is rolling out this
multi-step plan
the new Crackdown includes giving
first-time offenders intervention
programs instead of prosecution
de-escalation training for retail
employees establishing neighborhood
retail watch groups to share information
about a theft in real time with one
another and the police and installing
kiosks in stores to connect would-be
thieves with social service programs
the plan is to Target a small group of
serial shoplifters
the partnership what we are creating in
a city is two new diversion programs to
allow non-violent offenders to avoid
prosecution or incarceration by helping
them address underlying factors like
substance abuse or severe mental illness
327 people were responsible for the 22
000 arrests and remember those arrests
not actions many of them did the theft
and got away with it but it is not just
New York thieves are hurting communities
across the country the U.S Postal
Service even suspending delivery so an
entire zip code in Seattle due to a
spike in mail theft another idea judge
was you could arrest them
prosecute them why are we why are we
giving a chaos to 327 shoplifters the
whole idea that you know you try to hook
a thief up with a kiosk so they can get
Social Services is beyond first of all
who said stealing is an addiction
stealing is a decision that you make
because you want money or you want to
sell it to somebody else it isn't
because you need food and if somebody
steals for food in a supermarket I might
even look at that as a former D.A but
what I'm telling you is that this is
nonsense and the whole idea of
neighborhood watch for retail theft have
you seen some of the retail thefts in
these department stores they come in
with crowbars they break glass cases
they've got cars that are lined up to
take them off that run you over are you
kidding don't you dare get involved in
anything like that and they said well
look if they if we hook them up with a
kiosk it's a way they can get food
stamps you really don't think they can
get food stamps and the the whole idea
is that now the New York City under this
new prop program prop Precision repeat
offender program they want to keep a
list of the most persistent themes what
are they going to do help them like they
helped Jordan Neely who was on another
list of the 50 most mentally ill who
needed help I mean this is all talk no
action and you're putting civilians in
danger and you're giving the thief an
excuse they're also that when they talk
about de-escalation for the employees of
these stores I feel so bad for these
employees what are they supposed to I
mean they are the ones who are
completely caught in the middle I don't
know if you've been to the CVS bias but
I've been in there twice when someone
was trying to steal and the other person
was freaking out yelling at the people
behind the pharmacy he's trying to get
drugs and they're like we can't give
them to you sorry you need a
prescription it's like I'm in pain it's
like well I bet you are shaky but
they're already de-escalated because
they're completely passive because they
know if they in any way harm ahead on
the chinny chin or harm a hair on the
chinny chin chin of one of these
shoplifters they're going to get
prosecuted and Alvin Braggs New York
anyone who defends themselves or defends
a store or other Shoppers they are the
ones who are going to be in the system
and they're not first-time shoplifters
he just contradicted himself right said
387 people have been arrested 22 000
times that's not someone who's going in
contemplating should I get Gillette or
Bic no or should I just steal fifty
thousand dollars with things well part
of the problem is Jesse that they are
stealing all of these things and then
reselling them online
or taking them to a place where they are
sold online so there's no creativity in
the public policy process to figure out
how do you stop that if you stop that
incentive they're making money basically
on on sale online resales then there
should be a way maybe you could stop
that problem well you know who's really
making money is whoever got the kiosk
contract that's true true right I need a
kiosk guarantee you the guy's a donor to
the Adams campaign so this comes from an
academic ideology that capitalism
creates poverty and poverty creates
crime and if criminals just had more
welfare they wouldn't steal and we had
on a Serial shoplifter last night
who said
if you gave me a hundred thousand
dollars of welfare I'd take it and then
I'd keep stealing why because I'm
feeding my addict my addiction if you
have a drug addiction you're gonna steal
whatever you want whenever you want and
unless you're put in prison and hit rock
bottom that's the only thing that's
going to stop you now he said the reason
why people are
so drug addicted and and taking so many
things that don't belong to them he says
there's a spiritual black hole in
society and says when you don't believe
in anything higher than yourself
then I guess you're your own God and all
it's only about you and that's the
problem we have right now in this
country I've never heard you seem so
spiritual well I stole the line from
someone else and Geraldo it does seem
like this is another place where you see
like mayor Adams and not just him but
other Democrats who are trying to figure
out a way to deal with all the symptoms
but not the actual illness itself and
not just arresting the 327 because if
that seems like a common sense thing or
shut down the border that seems like
more common sense and trying to figure
out all of these Patchwork Solutions
well I agree with you and I actually
agree with the spiritual Jesse but and I
agree with mayor Adams I mean it's clear
that a few do most of the most of the
damage but here's the Geraldo plant I
have a plan first of all you have the
ban masks masks have served their
purpose now they are nothing but a
disguise for the crooks so no masks and
if a store doesn't want to go along with
the policy they don't put the sign up
that says no masks if you have wear a
mask you get you don't get served here
the other thing is I want anything of
value real value not food because the
judge is absolutely right you make an
exception I think for food
I want exploding dye the way they have
it in banks on cash why not anything of
value Beyond a certain amount you open
it up
the blue green neon is on you and then
you can scrub for weeks and it's not
going to go what if it gets on the
handbag then you can't sell the Chanel
but that might be okay better that than
reselling it on the internet yeah I
agree interesting well I still black
bags I think that is the takeaway here
yeah okay and no hoodies no hoodies all
right I got in a lot of trouble for that
I know you did that's why I brought it
up but I agree the judge is stirring up
trouble I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now